양자 정보와 계산 이해하기 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Matus이고, IBM
Quantum에서 교육 기술 총괄을 맡고 있어요. 이번 강의는 시리즈의 12번째 수업이고, 일반적인
양자 정보 공식화를 다루는 세 번째 단원의 마지막 수업이에요. 이 수업은 양자 정보의 핵심 개념인
양자 상태의 정화(purification)를 중심으로 다뤄요. 어떤 밀도 행렬로 표현된 양자 상태의 정화란
더 큰 복합 시스템의 순수 상태로, 나머지 복합 시스템을
버리거나 추적 소거(trace out)했을 때 원래 상태가 남는 거예요. 모든 밀도 행렬은 정화를 가지고 있고, 직관적인 수준에서 정화를 연구하면
양자 상태와 양자 정보 전반에 대해 많은 걸 배울 수 있어요.
순수 상태를 나타내는 양자 상태 벡터는 밀도 행렬보다 수학적으로 더 단순한 대상이에요. 그리고
상태의 정화를 생각하면, 임의의 양자 상태를 더 크지만
더 단순한 무언가의 일부로 볼 수 있어요. 또한 두 양자 상태 간의 Fidelity에 대해서도 이야기할 건데, 이건 두 상태의
유사성이나 겹침을 수치로 나타낸 값이에요. 특정 상태가 어떤
이상적인 상태와 얼마나 유사한지 측정하는 방법으로 자주 사용되죠. 특히 Fidelity의 정의와 기본 성질들을 살펴보고,
Fidelity가 정화와 어떻게 연결되는지 보게 될 거예요. 수업 개요를 먼저 살펴볼게요. 먼저 정화부터 시작하는데,
정의와 존재에 대한 간단한 증명을 다뤄요. 이를 통해 필요할 때 정화를 어떻게 찾는지 알 수 있죠. 그 다음엔 Schmid
분해라고 알려진 두 시스템의 양자 상태 벡터에 대해 다루고, Schmid 분해가 정화와 어떻게 관련되는지 살펴볼 거예요.
그 다음엔 같은 상태의 두 정화 사이에 존재하는 중요한 관계, 즉 유니터리
동치성(unitary equivalence of purifications)에 대해 다루고, 마지막으로 몇 가지 예제를 살펴볼 거예요. 그런 다음 Fidelity로 넘어가서
정의와 기본 성질들을 다룰 거예요. Fidelity를 측정과 연결하는 아주 유용한 사실인 gentle measurement Lemma에 대해서도 이야기하고,
마지막으로 수업을 마무리하면서 Fidelity와 정화 사이의 근본적인 관계를 확립하는 Uhlmann의 정리로 넘어갈 거예요.
정화의
정의부터 시작해 볼게요. 밀도
행렬로 표현된 상태의 정화란, 나머지
복합 시스템을 추적 소거했을 때 원래 상태가 남는 더 큰 복합 시스템의 순수 상태예요. 이걸 더 정확하게 수학적으로 표현하면
다음과 같아요. 시스템 X가 어떤 상태 ρ에 있다고 하면, 즉 ρ가 X의 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬이고,
S가 한 쌍의 시스템 XY의 양자 상태 벡터인데, y에서 순수 상태를 추적 소거했을 때
ρ가 남는다면, S를 ρ의 정화라고 해요. 물론 이름은 중요하지 않아요. 시스템과 상태의 이름은
마음대로 정할 수 있고, 시스템의 순서도 중요하지 않아요. 예를 들어
시스템 y가 오른쪽이 아닌 왼쪽에 있어도, 나머지가 모두 같다면 Ψ를 ρ의 정화라고 부를 수 있어요. 하지만
단순함을 위해 나머지 수업에서는 이 형태를 주로 유지할 거예요. 그리고 정의에 대해 처음으로 말할 건
정화는 항상 존재한다는 거예요. 모든 밀도 행렬 ρ에 대해, 더 정확히 말하면 모든
밀도 행렬 ρ는 정의에서 설명된 것처럼 정화를 가지는데, 시스템 y가 X만큼 크면 되는 거예요. 즉
y의 고전적 상태 수가 X 이상이면 돼요. 정화의 개념과
정화가 항상 존재한다는 사실은 매우 중요하고, 양자 정보를 아름답게 만드는 요소이기도 해요. 이 수업이 끝날 때쯤엔
그 사실을 납득시킬 수 있으면 좋겠어요. 이제 모든 밀도 행렬이 정화를 가진다는 걸 증명해 볼게요. 그 과정에서
필요할 때 정화를 어떻게 구하는지도 알 수 있어요. 정화의 정의에서와 마찬가지로
X가 시스템이고 ρ가 X의 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬이라고 가정해 볼게요.
이제 화면에 표시된 것처럼 ρ를 순수 상태들의 볼록 조합(convex combination)으로 표현한다고 생각해 봐요.
즉, 양의 정수 n을 선택하면 확률 벡터 p₀부터 p_과 양자
상태 벡터 ψ₀부터 ψ_이 있고, 확률로 가중된 해당 순수 상태들을 평균하면
ρ를 얻을 수 있어요. 예를 들어 스펙트럼 정리를 사용해서 이런 표현을 구할 수 있고, 그렇게 하면
n을 X의 고전적 상태 수로 설정할 수 있어요. 사실 n을 ρ의 랭크로 설정할 수 있는데, 이는
각 고유값의 중복도만큼 세어서 ρ의 영이 아닌 고유값의 개수와 같고,
X의 고전적 상태 수보다 크지 않지만 더 작을 수도 있어요. 반면에
ρ의 스펙트럼 분해가 아니어도 괜찮고, 이 양자 상태 벡터들이 직교할 필요도 없어요. 예를 들어 이런 형태의 ρ 표현은
다 괜찮아요. 그리고 ρ의 정화가 여기 있어요. 합산은
ρ 표현에서와 같은 값들에 걸쳐 있고, 합산 안에서는 확률의 제곱근을 F_a에 곱하고
|k_a⟩와 텐서 곱을 해요. 여기서 0부터 n-1까지가 두 번째 시스템 y의 고전적 상태라고 가정하고 있어요.
그래서 S가 정의에서처럼 쌍 XY의 양자 상태 벡터가 되는 거예요. 이 표현에서 Y의 표준 기저 상태를 사용할 필요는
사실 없어요. |k₀⟩부터 |k_⟩ 대신에 원한다면 임의의 정규 직교 집합을
대입할 수 있어요. 이제 y에 대한 부분 추적(partial trace)을 계산해서 이것이 실제로
정화인지 확인할 수 있어요. 부분 추적을 수행해서 얻는 상태의 표현이 여기 있어요.
⟨k_a|k_b⟩의 추적 값은 a와 b가 같으면 1, 다르면 0이에요. 그래서 표현이
원래 ρ 표현으로 단순화되고, 아주 간단하죠. 따라서 정화를 구하는 건 매우 쉬워요.
Y의 고전적 상태가 충분하거나, 대안적으로 사용할 수 있는 충분히 큰 정규 직교 집합이 있으면
|k₀⟩부터 |k_⟩ 대신 사용할 수 있어요. 그런데
Y의 고전적 상태 수가 ρ의 랭크보다 작으면 정화가 존재하지 않아요. 원하시면
직접 생각해 보세요. 예제를 살펴볼게요.
밀도 행렬 수업에서 여러 번 봤던 밀도 행렬을 생각해 봐요. 여기에 이
밀도 행렬을 순수 상태들의 볼록 조합으로 표현한 게 있어요. 스펙트럼 분해는 아니지만
상관없어요. 거의 아무 노력 없이 이 레시피를 따라서 상태의 정화를
바로 쓸 수 있어요. 이게 이 밀도 행렬의 유일한 정화는 아니에요. 정화는 유일하지 않지만 괜찮아요.